es momento un año después de haber
empezado esta invasión Margarita a hacer
balance de lo que ha significado esta
crisis humanitaria para Europa que ya
venía de una crisis humanitaria con los
sirios pero el trato no fue el mismo no
fue el mismo trato a los sirios a los
afganos y a los ucranianos aquí se le
critican no solamente Europa sino
también a los organismos internacionales
Sí de hecho Fíjate que hay una cosa bien
particular yo creo que hemos tenido
varias crisis en cuanto al tema de
refugiados derivadas Precisamente en su
mayoría pues una de la primavera árabe y
Las Guerras posteriores Las Guerras
civiles posteriores una es dos guerras
civiles en Libia y la otras la guerra
civil en Siria entonces claro el
recibimiento es completamente diferente
el recibimiento es completamente
diferente entre lo que pasa en el 2011
luego en el 2014 con el con estos dos
escenarios porque la acogida es
diferente y es diferente entre otras
cosas por una cuestión que siempre se
critica y es el tema cultural el tema
idiomático el tema de la étnico y la
posibilidad de adaptación de estas
poblaciones Ahora hay que tener en
cuenta una cosa en Ucrania o desde
Ucrania mejor tenemos dos momentos
importantes de migración de hecho
tenemos que hubo un momento primero en
el 2014 cuando se presentan toda la
primera la Primera Guerra Pues el
escenario de primer escenario de guerra
que es crimea y ya teníamos de hecho era
interesante porque hablándolo con una
amiga de la Cruz Roja que trabaja con
refugiados en España me decía que el
número más alto de refugiados era por
ejemplo ucraniano y después de Venezuela
es decir que ya teníamos un impacto en
migraciones ucranianas producto de lo
que había sucedido en crimea el euro
mayrán etcétera etcétera y ahora viene
esta nueva oleada migratoria que además
los lugares como tú lo mencionabas
vecinos son lugares de paso son lugares
de tránsito porque no están preparados
para acoger a este número personas y
esto necesita de todas maneras servicios
de salud de escuelas y el asilo el tipo
de asilo que se les estaba dando también
es estatus especial que se les daba
estatus de acogida es el nombre requiere
toda una cantidad de servicios que hay
que prestarle entonces esta mañana De
hecho escuchaba a alguien que decía Esto
fue como pilotear un avión mientras lo
estábamos construyendo hubo que
construirlo en el camino sin embargo
tiene algo a su favor Y es que los
consideraban europeos los consideraban
parte de su espacio y Los consideraban
Iguales no es un otro frente al que
ellos se definen sino iguales que
recibieron con ese sentimiento
humanitario con ese sentimiento de ayuda
y además partiendo de una premisa
fundamental y es aquí estamos frente a
una violación rampante del derecho
internacional donde un país está
invadiendo a un estado soberano sin
ninguna razón legítima Entonces yo diría
que el proceso de adaptación es
diferente pero en términos económicos el
impacto es mayor porque el estatus de
acogida me implica una serie de
beneficios que tengo que empezar a
otorgar de servicios de salud y eso le
cuesta a los Estados eso cuesta y cuesta
bastante pese a todo el mensaje que nos
envía en Europa y Estados Unidos es que
las vidas de unos refugiados valen más
que las de otros y esto es un gran
problema porque además Pese a que el
problema humanitario es grandísimo en
Ucrania y Pese que se les ha dado una
buena acogida usted lo estaba diciendo
el enfoque de los países ha sido militar
no humanitario Y eso lo podemos ver en
cualquier medio de comunicación que
usted abra por internet o físico y los
titulares están enfocados en la parte
militar en cuanto dinero se entrega en
Cuántas armas se entrega En cuántos
jefes de estado y de gobierno visitan
quiefo viceversa pero los refugiados
pasan un segundo plano y cada vez más se
descuida Entonces el enfoque realmente
importante que es el factor humano Sí
mira yo ahí Quisiera sacar como una
frase de es la siguiente nadie empieza
una guerra para hacer la paz Cuando una
guerra se inicia se inicia para la
victoria entonces aquí hay que separar
dos cosas yo creo que entre otras cosas
la respuesta humanitaria frente al tema
de refugiados ha sido una respuesta a
pesar de las dificultades de acogida
buena etcétera etcétera Pero en el plano
ya de la guerra en sí Lo que ambos
quieren es la victoria y cuando digo
ambos me refiero Rusia no entró y no
asumió los costos iniciales de esta
guerra para perderla y Jeff Ucrania no
está dispuesta tampoco acceder y
occidente no está dispuesto a que quien
pierda entonces hablar de Paz en este
momento es difícil hablar de una
solución una mediación como tú lo dices
que haya una presión internacional para
que eso ocurra es difícil porque las
condiciones no están dadas y no están
dadas por tres razones fundamentales la
primera todavía ambos creen que tienen
la capacidad para derrotar militarmente
al otro por eso lo que kiefmas hace es
pedir más ayuda militar la segunda razón
es que la capacidad negociadora en este
momento de Ucrania no es la mejor si
Ucrania negocia en este momento tendría
que negociar la quinta parte de su país
y obtener garantías de que Rusia no lo
va a invadir Y eso pasó en el 2014 y
pasó el año pasado